it may not be evident from the overall
numbers but when you look at a host of
other measures it's clear there is a
real crisis in the labor market
consider this one this just shows you
paid employees in the uk
across the uk it has fallen very sharply
such that now
it is down nearly three-quarters of a
million
jobs across the uk that's not the only
measure when you look at the number of
hours that people are working well
that's down sharply as well this goes
all the way back to 1992 showing you how
many hours across the economy
have been worked and just look at how
much has fallen
over the course of the last few months
that's never happened before totally
unprecedented as is the amount of people
who are facing
temporary suspension from work so they
are away from work temporarily now
this shows you these lines show you
basically in the previous three years
how many people the higher they are more
people have been temporarily away from
paid work let's add on this year and you
can compare
and contrast where you can see a very
big difference now this primarily
is all those people who have been
furloughed and it's up to around seven
and a half
million and the interesting thing is
when you kind of dig down into this and
look at the types of people we're
talking about
well it's rather uh interesting it's not
necessarily the same experience
for everyone actually if you look across
the uk at different regional
uh experiences with this the darker the
area the darker the regions of the uk
the more people are temporarily off work
and let's just zoom in and have a look
at a few of them london for instance
actually
is on the low side 19.3 of the workforce
uh temporarily off work but compare that
so that's about one in
five compare that with for instance the
northeast uh nearly a quarter
uh and the west midlands a similar
number up there so inequality
of different experience when it comes to
the labor market and inequality too when
you look at the different sectors
of the economy that are facing this so
uh agriculture far fewer people
followed their agricultural utilities
obviously health and education and
government but look
over here retail and hospitality other
services as well but retail and
hospitality
and construction the most hit the most
employees
uh being furloughed at the moment
temporarily unavailable to work
and we are getting that anecdotally each
day through new releases through new
news
of redundancy the latest debenhams
saying they're going to be two and a
half thousand job cuts unfortunately
most economists think
that won't be the end of it